hey don't people and a room in this is
the Reuben report and we are doing the
biggest gayest show we've done we do a
lot a gay stop here
been a big gay year usually good news I
have brought
to you too gay s gay superstars
hank Chen Davey wavey I think that
they're not guys
yeah the gayest want you guys where I
look through the list and get you to
people and both have you are on the top
it'll work there
and here we are you get you ready to be
gaining some more where are you right
now so this is
this should be very cold hard so
exciting there you go
all right let's talk to get up we
actually got some great game news this
morning
Derrick Gordon who is a division one
basketball player at US came out
he is the first division 1 basketball
player to come out this of course comes
on the heels of Jason Collins
in the NBA michael fay am I NCAA
football player who will make it to the
NFL in a couple months
at you better be jocks right there
to get too big jock here to talk sports
I dorgan outside yeah
can we agree that there whether you're
an athlete or sports better not wholly
agree that
having another out athlete is all good
as a message is good news right
I love it I i think any kinda visibility
and
no matter who it is is fantastic i I
think the power coming out
is through the individual and not to
like policy using government
opinions and laws and stuff like that it
has to be the personal
connections I'm sure he's got that
ripple factor his immediate circle and
that's going
you know the people to have a process
that decide whether to accept them for
who is our
cut off yeah operates the form all good
all good well I mean that's it's it's
breaking stereotypes it's like this is a
guy who is not a hair dresser which is
what we see with gay people on TV
he's he's something different a I mean
the question that we had was is he any
good
yeah so he's pretty decent that's what I
and no text back on Yahoo both the
dribbling lyle
with the orange ball brøndby area code
in
the Decatur who've been there only right
that when that one spot
yeah it would be like that so okay so
it's all good when do we get to stop
celebrating this stuff because I think
at some point we do have to get past
like
everybody that comes out we have to like
a crazy ride it literally is the number
one trending on Twitter as a
are taping this like where are we are we
close to that point where we can
just be like oh you came out great we're
just not the writer not
I don't want her though you know I this
makes me think I shouldn't have come out
I should've like how the seeker for
here's and then we had this big thing to
get so much publicity from it
when none of us would ever be talking
about this guy right wanna be trending
on Twitter
but now he is and and it's great that he
came out but this is like
millions and millions of dollars a
publicity yeah I think that it is using
points over three public people that are
out is
is there a little bit home resentment or
something obviously we're not NCAA
happening but is there a little bit up
like oh I could have held it in until
something big happen and that it would
have an even bigger
something like that I cannot have held
it in anyone want to middle school
knowing that I cannot have held it and
yeah but also I don't think I would be
here sitting at this desk with you had I
not come out YouTube was my
public outing and to answer your earlier
question I feel like we should never
stop celebrating I mean are we really
gonna at a certain point canceled a gay
pride parade because no longer relevant
I every year they ever hear that it's
Pride Month people can talk about
anything lol no cuz every black person
with an Oscar I
feel like that's also noteworthy in that
in the civil rights you know for
for other group has had continue yeah
in spite of its longer history then the
gay rights movement it's great
do you guys think that the the sports
thing is more about the
you're from the media or actually what
goes on in the locker room
because that's what everyone thinks that
somehow if there's a gay person in the
locker room even though they're
obviously have been gay people in the
locker room forever on tap for a long
time
that somehow that's get the players are
gonna freak out but I i to me it's more
about the media how the media is gonna
react
the natural players I really think
they're going at a rally people probably
just don't care
I guess 2014 and the players are
probably be like that that's great he
pleaded right let's go play the game
yeah
by its kinda I think the it's like the
net it's become a talking point this
year it's like that next barrier the
next thing to break through
yeah when do you think last question on
this when do you think we will have been
openly straight WNBA player
and who I think when you're did you get
the joke air got together I did
IIIi hopefully soon black lesbians in
that we we support we support you
there's always Wednesday I think that
the perfect hit me openly support
great women in the WNBA
okay let's move on at see you guys
probably heard about this whole Mozilla
Firefox CEO
fallout situation up Brendan ike
I is the CEO or was the CEO of Mozilla
until last week he donated thousand
dollars to prop eighty
in 2008 the bad side of prop 8 and then
OK Cupid found out about this and they
blocked
the their site OK Cupid on Mozilla
Firefox browser
hello there Mozilla Firefox user part in
this interrupt you know you're OK Cupid
experience Mozilla's new CEO Brendan I
can
opponent equal rights for gay couples we
would therefore prefer that our users
not use Mozilla software
to access OK Cupid okay so then of
course this blowed up
into I blew up into a giant fire storm
he stepped down
but now it turns out that there might be
a little hypocrisy here
because the CEO OK Cupid has that
donated money
to to some things that perhaps
he's not so proud have now okay cubans
founder and CEO San Diegan made a five
hundred dollar donation to a
congressional candidate who oppose
same-sex marriage voted against the ban
on sexual orientation based job
discrimination and
or probation and gay and options records
show that you can who's also the scene
York Match dot com donated $500 dollar
to representative Chris cannon is
republican in Utah in 2000
and poor I so before we get to the
hypocrisy for this guy
were you guys happy to see the CEO bozo
going at it is a thousand dollars that
he did
a roughly five years ago I think about
in dollars I think it's a significant
amount of money and I think you know
when people with they put your money
where your mouth is
people vote with their dollars so enough
and also it's not just that money it's
also
his or lack thereof on like retracting
or even
are the statements supporting that
donation even years later
right so we have no indication that he
doesn't still feel that way
out but a lot has changed in five years
and it is possible that change and it
was only a thousand dollars so was this
a bit
up an overreaction disorder he didn't
get fired he stepped down
yeah I think he had the opportunity to
say you know what league it was 2008
things are different now I have evolve
my
thoughts on gay marriage and and you
know i i shouldn't have done that he had
some opportunity to kinda apologize
yeah and he really just kinda stayed
with that and I had so even if he's got
have been evolved rush chimney shady
have the right now but should someone be
have the right to be the CEO
a pretty public company and not be four
gay marriage in it's an interesting
question I guess maybe the answer is
probably yes but I think it's I don't
think of our business that they are
doing it will mark the lobby see
yet to agree I means and you know I
didn't like
you know green people I wouldn't say it
because likely for my customers a green
yeah in like it just it just going to be
shut your mouth
recognise or yeah don't know it was just
like such a distraction but he kind of
had to
if they were going to move forward at
all in your he had he had had to step
down
what you guys think about the the
hypocrisy the OK Cupid so he banned
the Mozilla the you know explore or
whatever
and for insight but it turned out that
he has donated to something that he may
not be so proud of two
but I think the difference being that
since this is like years and years later
he has had the opportunity to say you
know i i supported the stand I don't
support it now
and so I think people can come to make
that difference she Asian yeah
I are you are you guys fans love Urban
Outfitters
manager I like Urban Outfitters yeah I
think that t shirt might be a bit is it
not
it's not going to take it off yeah I
trust you I know you go ahead we'll take
it up have a lower
yeah but because the owner at the
president and founder of Urban
Outfitters has donated money to rick
santorum's campaign he said some other
anti-gay step
so it is weird how we sorta pick and
choose who we decide to relegate what we
can do that and you keep all the time
everywhere something that is from Urban
Outfitters and people recognize that
people
email me India you wore that shirt from
Urban Outfitters a camp leaders
supporting their
so when your personal policy on that so
you do where Urban Outfitters despite
knowing that I mean I full disclosure I
had plenty of Urban Outfitters yeah I
mean I II
didn't realize when I bought the shirt
that I was
you know in the worked on the internet
you can't win no matter what you do
yeah and and you can try to tread as you
couldn't you could donate a million
dollars to schools Africa
people email you and say you know
there's a lot of work that needs to be
at home who are you
rent writer I alright so with every
thought since we're winning the war
you're right that we're winning this
game more its I mean we're getting gay
marriage in every state every couple
weeks
some activist judge does something we
get the more gay marriage
okay doing in a weird way that the gay
community should somehow figure out a
way to be a little more gracious
somehow for these people should be
bigger not gracious exactly which we
figure out a way to be a little more
open to these people that maybe did
things five years ago
that whether they're proud of it or not
I don't putting I know it's putting it
on us
which i think is very difficult because
we still don't have for quality but I
think there's something to that
that there's these people holding on to
something that they're losing and maybe
we should somehow figure out a way to
embrace them a little bit warns that
everyone is fighting on
I can go out to work with yeah I think
the question that people are trying to
ask is even if he felt this way
have your top profit the default do you
feel this way now
and that giving people that giving
people who are in positions of power and
influence on the public eye
opportunity either yes or now and
you know we've all we all grow and learn
I'm not the same person I was five years
ago and and so
people are wanting to see where their
leader stand today and so I think
the leaders who are not being as tactful
as they should be are getting a little
bit a blowback
your yet another yeah I I am I don't
care so much what someone said
ten years ago and when the whole thing
with the gay rights movement is that
we're hoping to change hearts and minds
in when we do that with someone we can
hold that against them
that that their opinion is now different
and and I think that's a great thing
if they still think that I should get
married I want I will not have
compassion give him a problem yeah
alright well said okay let's talk about
the gay mafia because that's been the
big story this week
because Bill Maher on overtime which is
the online only show
that they do on real time after the show
he implied that they're actually is a
gay mafia
let's take a look what do you think the
Mozilla CEO having to step down over his
donation to pro proposition 8 per be a
the Mozilla which I'm wearing right now
by the way
I didn't know what was the law was not
on my computer but
the its its Firefox rated the browser
open and feed oh this guy apparently
does not want gay people to get married
and the he had to step down
what do you think about the question is
because he gave a thousand dollars eight
years ago
units come back to haunt when he gave it
when President Obama
still with the anti-marriage so I don't
think it's very fair good point
also I think there is a gay mafia
my I think if you cross them
you do get whacked I
okay I think there were some I had the
sexual connotation to the way he said
whacked
was in there something there there's
back rows behind you lol
Apple era yeah something at the end so
it's a little bizarre
okay so they talk a little bit about the
Mozilla CEO is we just did in the
previous segment
I but keep the way bill says that he's
half joking
but the way he sorta leaning in his
chair is also like
yeah I mean this thing I'm a in the
hollywood
I'm pretty entrenched and I know this
thing exists
so you to professional gay people does
the gay mafia exist anyway no comment
yeah
a have a champagne me it really a good
thing that
you know they don't think that you don't
think there's an organized group a game
people that are meeting somewhere their
power for hauling in another organize I
think that occur but gave
I think they're gay friends circles as
there aren't any professional
year setting and they do favors for each
other I don't believe that anyone is
pulling strings them all beloit yeah
right so with the right-wing people cuz
we got a list the things that people
claim that the gay mafia guys
they say that the you know they started
the fire storm a duck dynasty think that
was the gay mafia
but then the game I feel of that when I
guess is that anything a lot Alec
Baldwin everybody's
paper 8 monger he likes get MSNBC that
must be the gay mafia
and that the CEO obviously a month or so
you guys really don't you just don't
believe
well I think what there is probably a
group of very wealthy game and that get
together and decide like whitkin what
candidates they're gonna find where
they're gonna put their money
the things they're gonna try to
influence with their dollars I don't
think that they're like
thinking that they're gonna make some
fire storm about duck dynasty I know the
media
yeah and I think the job with the
firebox like it's its
public opinion that that this guy was
like gay mafia now is public opinion
that's why he step down
I so I that I agree with that what
they're calling gay mafia really is just
glared HR seeing
the rest that up which wedding like
those organizations are not every group
in this country has their advocacy
groups that are trying to
to do things would be the worst thing in
the world if we actually had a gay mafia
if the really if it came out yes there's
a group of gay people
trying to pull some strings for the gay
people become more equal
and you see better image is a gay people
immediately clear we got beat up
it's very like that the answer is no but
I think the gay mafia are all the 14
year old white girls
ont where bad backup there
people like you yeah into and I will
come to your defender your
over everything is everything going on
the host a shirtless video it all the
14-year-old girls that click like the
year old man yeah
yeah I did back in the real game your
YouTube video at playlist live
and I had to kiss straight guys in it
and I was like no one is gonna kiss me
but no sorry guys can do this I have
like 60 14 overalls running with me up
to these guys like
for that is the battery mafia yeah
he kissed me yeah they're alright ok oh
my what I met a good to hear every not
dead
I alright well there you have it I
brought onto professional gay youtubers
I know a little something about this
write-up
and we don't know if there is a game at
which maybe means we're on
were on the outs probably are guided by
the thin guys at this is really around
away are really
way if any work we're going to do yeah
Korea okay according to Egypt this week
sentenced for men
up to eight years in prison for yeah
homosexuality
prosecutors had accused the men
upholding quote DB and parties
and they're using a law that bans
debauchery
to to put these guys in jail and put
them on trial
at the middle east seems to be pretty
backward as we've talked often about
related to anything with human rights
women's rights gay rights that are there
we've got a map that gives you a little
more
about gay rights around the globe and
basically
red and the darker red you are the worse
it is
blue in the darker blue you are the
better it is and
and grey it's pretty it's pretty decent
I'm
how do we get the Middle East into the
21st century
I get it we're not perfect here we do
not have full marriage equality here we
got plenty of problems here
but how do we get that section of the
world to at least come a little
bit further in this direction well funny
you should say the work comin that
question my head that they look at their
own history
be chipped Kate you cleopatra who with
what are the more sexually deviant
characters
in in history apparently this woman used
to have 100 the men contribute to her
back have
good for her skin or whatever and I was
like a now we have an issue with
one-on-one
I was like I don't nurse I don't
understand the logic 100 amended what
the contributor her bath contribute
comin about tub and she would baby and
it I've never heard that are you kidding
me it's all over the internet
yeah but
I've never so she was in a greater sense
memory like I think yeah
she would be throughout I did not know
that through it it wanted she
bitch with actually be and whether or
not that I like a mythological whatever
your own immunity idol like
in every II look at all these
conservative culture even like Asian
me outlets you know a lot of players
myself Chinese history there somewhere
to ship that went down and then they're
like
all know gay people know gay people are
like really am because the all the time
came yeah shit back in your dynasty in
the NRL
Yap do we have any right to take it to
the quest to help her that had a nice
why I don't get them to look at their
own history in Riyadh
the hypocrisy in you know that where did
we come from where we going
well I guess that in the case and yet so
if that's a place where science
and the liberalism were rewarded a
little more a long time ago and exhorted
gone backwards do we have any bright in
the United States to
tell these people had a live 1900
YouTube commenters are going to say no
cuz everytime I pose that question
everyone yeltsin's as you know right we
need to mind their own dinner it's a
difficult yet
which should we care about the their
human rights well I think we should my
my we are human beings and we are tied
by that threat by
ate the most viewed country is Saudi
Arabia which is
interest right on that map in Colorado
you know in and
it's amazing I think what's being done
on YouTube not that we're saving the
world are curing cancer
or you know but I think it is a stout
in a journey towards getting people to
move a little bit forward with the way
that they
you gay rights do you get a lot of
comments from
for people from Saudi Arabia nah party
rockers we did a video last week about
women driving in saudi arabia
and I actually got a lot of men from
Saudi Arabia angry
saying that women shouldn't be allowed
to drive in if you let women drive is
going to be more car accident or the
and I kinda feel bad for them more than
anything else because they're just being
indoctrinated
break with this stuff and so it's like I
can't hate
am really because that's what they're
being taught but you get a lot of
comments on your videos I didn't want to
be males
from people that are in countries where
it's like not as accepted but the
the important thing is that you're
starting a dialogue when you're starting
a conversation that they might not
otherwise have
yeah Kenwood is it going to solve all
the problems and no but maybe it's going
to get the ball moving a little bit
yeah is there anything that the
government should do I me should we be a
key chip is our ally we give them a lot
of money
should that be contingent on human
rights I think
I think we should tread carefully cuz I
don't understand what's going on
in you when it comes to business affairs
I don't run the country and not a
policymaker because I know there's a lot
policymaker I trench and I thought I
already said policy-making hear them to
me neighbor to make it worth it to me
out what you know i mean there's a lot
that goes on %um
we're not gonna wheel wheeling and
dealing with between his world leaders
and I think in order to protect American
interests we have to tread carefully
when we turn as in other peoples
business
but without being fed human to human I i
think thats why we do what we do because
I like reaching people on a personal
level I to get a lot have
people in these very conservative
country is
including the Middle East as well as
parts of Asia who in the closet and are
scared
and I do what I can from that level but
I
and that that's the only thing I'm able
to do at this point but I kept
when I get around as their little part
by the way we should note that gay
cities which is a big a website
they did their poland what the best gay
city is in the world and last year
it was tel-aviv Israel just smack in the
middle the Middle East what is with
those crazy jus their hair down
with the gays while everybody else
around them seem to want to kill barbara
walters et after 50-plus
years doing network television she has
announced her retirement
and earlier this week on The View she
actually gave us a date
let's take a look you may remember that
last spring I said that I would leave
daily television
in a year so here we are it's almost one
year later
and I have decided that Friday May 16
will be my final appearance on The View
as a cost
Co
for will be a two-hour ABC news
primetime special
looking back at my career for all the
time should be continuous years on the
air
for man I've been doing to YouTube show
for a year and I think that's a long
time
fifty consecutive years on air so what
about Barbara
first and then we'll talk about the view
why is it that barbara walters doesn't
get into that gay
icon status that these older women seem
to get into a course for me the Golden
Girls
but all there's just plenty of older
women I
you know judy garland whoever that the
gate me let for some reason barbara
walters even though she's a proponent of
gay rights and is on TV every day and
talking about liberal causes
thing like that she never made it bear
for some reason why does I find it hard
to trust anyone with eyes that are just
that day
it work but you don't have a problem
with the woman with work Amanda
now yeah I don't know I think that she
comes across as like a little
pretentious at the same time I
appreciate the barriers that she is
broken down and then she was like
really at the forefront what she was
doing I'm but
I just don't feel like the same warm
fuzzy how much she kinda
3 music on to help kinda
Wow time stroll NRA to that point is
that is it partly because she's a
newswoman so she's more serious than
gays like over the top i right days like
amp
yet she doesn't have a drag doppelganger
i think is nothing apart and you're
right
it's hard to impersonate her and i cant
yeah all our icons are performers
mostly yeah the easier to emulate and
Betty White is a comedian even though
she's not a thinner
your help but shouldn't we love someone
like barbara walters who did break down
all those barriers and is actually doing
something i mean she did
she did for women what we want someone
to do
for gay people are I think we do however
I love her I highly respect her I think
she spears at how the way she like rain
then
the view in like but Ochoa both down
had at least about a lot brings a man
and I think people really respect your I
certainly really adore her and I think
she is back I had to be inspirational in
very ambitious II but I think you
I never thought about this but yeah
she's difficult to
Icona I whatever whatever that word it
was alright let's talk with the manual
because I i think there's something
really fascinating with the view and gay
people I
there was a couple years where i watch
with you every day when rosie was I'm
I enjoy it was on I they were so amazing
together there
rosy obviously is gay joy is as close to
gay as possible I get out here today
I am what is it about the view and what
is it about a group of women that are
outspoken
that gays go out because if they were to
show up by gay guys sitting around table
for gay guys
gays would not be in doubt we will ever
but also what is that what is that
well i'd at I I like to watch it because
I to see how a disinterested enjoy is
instances like trying to get through the
shower this is just like is this really
another week the PO the base probably
why she left review after
what we're shooting for 12 years and a
yeah its I
I think you can't pay all gay people the
broad-brush that like all the people
like the view
but it's the same reason I people like
the video its it's a distraction from
everyday life
like there's a lot of drama there's a
lotta cattiness that goes on
yeah and and you know people people like
that but it was in a meeting where
yes yeah I click on a link to this link
meeting was okay at a %uh okay
right what is it you know about what is
it though about gay guys
that I are you guys with me that if it
had been a table for gay guys that it
never would have done
nearly as well as having women I
maybe middle age women would have liked
it I the middle age women love gay guys
but that gay guys would have been as
into it
if it had been gay guys at the table I
agree I think it's I think there's not
as wide appeal
if it's all just game and but that's a
cultural thing for another you let
another side conversation but i'm
talking about. board game and watching
it what what why is it that gay men
would be more inclined to watch
a group for women at a table then game
at a table I think it's the same reason
why
game and club back from the city cuz
that show
does were gay men masquerading as women
I think vida
the captive the view on those are gay
men masquerading as women I think this
comes they just remind us I'll
private conversation that we have I
think we love the passion we love the
hair with there's a there's a certain
element love go I am and and it its
elevated
it heightened its our lives heightened
for you now and now you're right we
campaign it with the bitter big brush
but
it their appeal is the same reason that
the reality shows
have appeal yeah and fashion shows have
appeal
so so there you go yeah II pilot on it I
was thinking you know barbara said the
thing about the the fifty years and all
that
do you think that's just like a thing
that's a long time people that are going
to have the sourdough
iconoclastic I think they were there we
have worked
careers where they last 50 years in the
business
is she really wanted the sorta for and
when a caller dinosaur but you know what
I mean is she
is that it really that we won't have
people that last this long in this kinda
business
well I mean it up I don't think so i
think there's going to be other people
that they're doing that but the
important thing with Barbara Walters is
really she broke down so many
barriers that stood in her way that
lately in that sense she's
legendary much she did right and there
will be other people the front other
game doing things have never been done
but those were some like really
big walls to break down yeah so I get
there aren't that many walls to break
down
hope right now I think deeper was it
just a pop-up not refer her
right now so a copper people love her
you know not for white women
broadcasting
record here the other walls to break
down well speaking of walls to break
down
there's a good chance we're gonna have a
female president in 2016
occurred this hillary Clinton women
apparently she's gonna run for president
that on everything
and as we are doing our big a
spectacular show this week I want to
talk about why
gays love Hillary we were just talking
about why gays
sorted don't love barbara walters but
gays love
freakin Hillary clinton everyday lives
here they just a huge
fundraiser for the her at the abbey here
in West Hollywood
kinda gays were there she's getting all
the money gays gays voted
far more for her in 2008 than they did
for Barack Obama
what is it about Hillary and the gay we
know I think it's
it's a mutual appreciation because my
first gay pride parade was 2005 New York
City
in in the world that gay rights like
that was a lifetime ago that was a very
different world than where we're at now
yeah and she was marching in a parade
yeah and I he was senator from New York
yet
and I was like so on Presley there she
was with her rainbow flag
and so I think part of the reason why we
love her is because
she support us so a.m. now every day
like Sir
by the way yeah there's something I
don't Highland here and I personally in
good conscience can't vote for another
clinton or bush I just simply will not
do interest we left England for a reason
and I don't think
that families I've never had anyone in
my family that was president have you
guys
not yet yes I'm pretty sure they don't
need more about you know he could ever
Just Cavalli at 20:26 I
so I can't get no I don't know where
Obama that really thickening the
worshipping at these people
I do you think she's gonna suffer in a
weird way from every democrat 2016 is
gonna be for gay rights right i mean it
in the party platform
so in a weird way she's gonna lose a
little gay support because gays
won't have to vote at these democratic
gays
in the primaries won't have to vote on
gay issues
defile me I do she gets on your team
because she gave gonna get it either
she's gonna get you get here it is
simply because above her history and you
know I
in I with that the 2005 pride parade it
might have been seven at the time I'm
just getting more than that but
I remember her speech a thirty-minute
speech she gave at the UN
yeah and that was also very progressive
I believe that was 2010 11
Radha and and and I was like that ball
the because
she speaking to these countries that we
mentioned earlier that are very
conservative and actually
have a lot that persecute gay people and
I so I think gave my her because
to the car harness that the people give
this story
to yet and she would be she would be the
first female president and I
in I think like people for better ways
that people people
that's part of it we at Sparta the kinda
amor and in
that she's just so credible up to this
order goes to our talk about with the
you but do you guys think that if there
was a game male
that had the exact same resume
I guess that would be tough because she
was first lady but if there was a gay
male who had the same exact
in terms of voting record and being pro
gay and all that
that the gays would embrace that person
I think the gays war okay right now I'm
gonna get yelled at
while I am NOT an umbrella
well now amongst other boy as we all
know that there's plenty of segregation
discrimination it within the gay
community as well someone get the keys
to that something is going to not
someone's gonna one after the top or
bottom thing and have an opinion about
that I think
I it's sad to say I don't know if the
gay community with fully back gay
candidate I think we have to look at
that gay candidates are the gay a
congressman the case enters a curly Rd
in office and see what that kinda voting
record has been like but
yeah unfortunate we're just picky eater
yeah I don't think there's something
about
in and I don't know how best to say this
but
that league not all game and enjoy
seeing
other game in sixty to hear what you
think sook
like a roll over there that happens that
Lake
where they're very quick to cut other
gay man down yeah
so that's what I was talking about with
that you think we're so what do you
think that about because I do think I'd
absolutely think if there was a
openly gay the candidate running for
president
they had the same exact platform is
Hillary the gays would not be into him
and I i don't know what the answer is I
it's really interesting but on a micro
level you guys are gay YouTube urs
I mean don't you get plenty of hate from
the gay community yeah more heat from
the gay community than from
the straight community a yeah edges I
and I don't know doing your own little
world what do you
what do you make that at I think it's
its a
very complex question and I think I
don't know I don't know what the easy
answers but I think what I've seen is
like a man are very
kinda quick to cut each other down that
Drake
and I think that's not something that
just happens in the gay world I think it
happens with women seeing other women
succeed
I'm heard this from my friends a and as
I think it's like a phenomenon that
happens and marginalized communities
yeah I it's not it's not a good look I
but it's hardly
when it is over but the look for in a
row 10 yeah you agree with that
I do I think it's just a projection
above our own insecurities and the
things that we had to deal with
and during our coming-out process and it
in its sometimes it's difficult to be
happy
for other people when it comes to to
their success and I was gonna say
if you wanna project the public opinion
on up
potential gay presidential candidate you
can just look at the Mercatus liberties
now every public gave
celebrity entertainment usually a can be
a little bit of a lightning rod for
controversy even Anderson Cooper who is
pretty as the No as they come
people Obama people hate and we're
talking about just the gays
right yet yeah well you know you've
given me a perfect segue here because we
got one more segment for your
and this is on the glass closet I
thought to be perfect talk to these guys
about it if you don't know the term the
glass closet
it is I'm gonna read this because I want
to get a fully right it is a term used
for a gay person usually a public figure
or celebrity
who has never publicly come out as being
gay but he's basically known
to be gay there are many of these people
now I'm not gonna out anyone
we had a debate before the show I'm not
going to out anyone here
but I have written four names here on
this piece of paper
I don't want you guys to repeat these
names but there are four teams here
that are very very public people I in
Hollywood wanna major TV star
won a major movie star won a major music
music star
it cetera that pretty much everyone in
the gay community knows he's gay
again I am NOT outing any when I just
want you guys to look at this
with keep an eye on me for a second so
that the white shutters and even see
this
okay now we're just looking at that one
of them's begin news and sort it has
been how did recently by a major
newspaper
okay map my question is this: yes
with these people I have no reason to
think that any of them are anti-gay
actually some Obama done publicly
pro-gay things
but yet they still refuse to just say
and I'm curious as
out people you guys put a lot of stuff
out there you put your both felt out
there
you put a lot of skin out there I got
but I i a
yeah literally your but your skin in the
game via I M Google held
skin into his K whatever whatever works
yeah really how I i cuz I feel very
conflicted by these people I have no
doubt that they're all good people
and private we doing good things and
prolly living happy lives in all at
but as out people how should we feel
about this group of people that sorta
tacitly endorsing
this idea that you can live your life
still
but don't say either wanna view
take it away I would say that the coming
out process
is different for everyone and that
there's no
right way to do it there's no time that
you need to do a by and
and not the number letting any of them
off the hook
but that there probably at
potentially a different points in the
coming out journey into I think it's
very
hard to be critical love people and
and in where they're at and we see the
same thing with
with you keepers like that there's
youtubers better in the closet
and it's easy for us as oughtn't versus
a
what were you doing way come out you can
do so much for the cause you help change
hearts and minds
but babe just might not be very I i mean
there's a lot
a processing the house the happened to
get to that point right now get I don't
know anymore they're waiting for the
book deal
who so that's a big maybe what a whore
because I don't know any these people
personally but
I'm good at the poor people that I wrote
down here I'm pretty sure these are all
millionaires
probably multimillionaires a n isn't
that that tacit endorsement
that they're sorta saying what I could
lose this you not to lose my TV show I
could lose my movie
it senator isn't that sorted the worst
message you could be sending to
a 15-year-old that maybe want to go in
the movies
Iranian want to be an actor is in the ER
is mid a subliminal message there that
this is almost like the worst thing you
could possibly do
and I mean if I were to speculate and
I'm rock not really in a position to do
so I can only speak from my own
experience but one of them is also
fairly quite young
as prominent a figure as he is is yeah I
think people is pretty so I would I
think that if their own
emotional journey and I have no problem
with them choosing to remain in the
closet
because they are so prominent in the
public eye
as long as you're not living a life of
pot hypocrisy so ready as if you're not
a
you know vocally voting yet voting
against gay rights or start expressing
your disdain
yeah then we're cool and as far as I
know
most of these people have also been
vocal supporters
%uh gay rights they just never join the
club themselves a bit like the bike oh
yeah he's a great love gave
that not me but let gay rights ok that's
the weird thing and I think that's why
everyone feels so conflicted when I
showed you guys this list
both sorta backed up like oh shit we
better not talk about that with good
there is
this unsaid thing right that we
shouldn't really if we were to say this
these names people go berserk right I do
when I respect people's privacy I know
they're coming out with
a difficult process for myself and I
wasn't even
online when that happened it was just my
own little world I was so unbelievably
afraid so one can imagine just what
they're going to do as I wanna be
responsive
tell that I would like to and once
they're out I i tell me your story girl
let's let's let's hear it what do I do
with I totally agree cuz that's why did
the senate like this and in plastering
under the is the hypocrisy issue is that
the big one for you if you saw these
four names and saw that one of them was
somehow doing some sort I had a gating
with that lead you more
right I i mean that's what what means
bad
well bad taste in your mouth so it's a
so sorry yeah
media mountain happy belated yeah I got
I think that's where cross the line in
the message that you were saying I love
like you know they're millionaires and
they're afraid there
that's probably not the message that
they think that they're putting out I
agree I don't think they're proactively
believing that they're doing something
bad but I do think especially
for one of these people who is an actor
who was it so hugely successful
there is somehow the implication that my
success is based
and me not coming out and I think that's
really dangerous
and I i that doesn't mean I'm gonna out
him or even think I don't even think
poorly of him I don't know him
but I i think that that conflicting
message is still something that the gay
community
is hasn't quite grappled people only
think the message that he's putting our
is is not in your fucking business
and and this is my personal life in its
in it doesn't matter should be it
like the methods that were receiving
isn't the same message that he thinks
he's putting out
a and and a big kind is what it is
yet I don't bother valid yeah I think
his perspective it is
there is out there are certain things
that as public as I am there something
that I just don't talk about pressure
and you're not going to get me to talk
about them to get the flavor
condemned it will you at least write
them on this paper rather not take this
I don't talk about my out and buying raw
any relationship collect seen
youtuber celebrities we all thought you
know when you get into a very public
here a man to contain commands in the
public eye
it just the parts never very good I know
when you started your blog you talk
about way friends gather you were dating
yeah separating church and state they
will keep something secret for him his
insect oriented for some these people
sexual orientation
might be sacred space for them I don't
know I'm now going to crush list and
burn it
so I don't tell you saw that hatch and
Davey wavey
thank you guys the use of you are you
were a little nervous to do something
with the jury on but I think people that
I yeah
death of my comfort zone deck with the
girls covered up I have to say
back in filthy that their it but yeah
very calm your
very iight well don't forget to like and
comment I'm a youtuber there you really
know about it like comment subscribe
is there any others tell them to do
follow us on Twitter their twitter is a
ride down below
anything other anything %uh I'll post a
picture about on Instagram well
at any better well they should they
could do it you and put away I mean less
than what it looks like before the bout
with
all your social media tumbler come round
where the I would bet
I to them got everybody I
up